tu crois que c'est sorti de l'auberge
toi ben je sais pas c'est qu'elle
rencontre avec moi interview complète un
médiateur au confessionnal tout le
raconte le mouvement
agnès est ce que tu t'es déjà confié oui
beaucoup
quand j'étais petit quand j'étais à
partir de partir de ma profession de foi
j'ai été élevé par les soeurs
j'étais au à l'institut des jeunes
filles saint joseph où après les bonnes
manières
est-ce que tu approuve le divorce
oui oui tout ça plutôt versé par essence
entend par ce que tu approuve la
contraception
est-ce que tu approuve la sexualité par
mariage
est-ce que tu éprouves l'homosexualité
ce qui va est-ce que tu retrouves
l'appartement pas comme méthode de
contraception mais comme recours à a
détresse oui je te rappelle aux pêcheurs
nomades dans les piscines en tête voient
déjà
je me suis appliqué à oublier toute
cette culpabilisation que j'ai subies
pendant mon enfance
et quand c'est ce qu'a consistait à
envoyer aux professionnels a confiance
qu'on m'a donné je me souviens très bien
on était dans l'est dans les couloirs de
devant la chapelle et on se demande est
ce qu on allait dire et c'est j'ai copié
sur des péchés de deux camarades de
classe et je me souviens que l'on
m'avait demandé de faire quelques je
vous salue marie quelques votre père
mais ensuite j'ai fini puisque j'ai payé
pour ses péchés
je vais pouvoir les commettre et
c'est je ne savais pas du tout où ni
l'esprit à faire ces choses là comme
deux volets 20 centimes dans la porte me
donne ma mère et c'est le concept du
péché qui m'a donné l'idée la recherche
de visages sont donc fausses annonces
google et les sept péchés capitaux
je les ai connus
tu ne tueras point ses dix commandements
alors je sais plus je confonds tout ce
que tu pêches par orgueil
forcément on est obligé d'être d'être
orgueilleux un petit peu par envie celle
envie qui
ce qui nous pousse à à avoir la force
d'obtenir des choses c'est pas mal tout
ça va pas empêcher ça
un bonbon moteur par luxueux alors la
luxury à yala mme morales
qui vient s'entrechoquer avec la
l'éducation faut pas oublier que j'étais
très jeune en 68
donc moi j'ai vécu la libération
sexuelle la pilule donc la rupture
situé près de la fosse située à ma
personne mais qui tu es ça dépend si
cette personne ne mérite ou pas je
capable de me donner de l'amour comme si
on disait que j'avais la gangrène je
serai capable de mutiler d'un membre
je pense beaucoup de gens ne lisent jeu
si j'étais handicapé je préfère l'amour
est en jeu j'ai déjà failli mourir je
préfère être handicapé plutôt que de
mourir et
je préfère vivre sans la personne que
j'aime c'est là négatif plutôt que que
négativement avec la personne que
j'aimais je crois au bien et au mal mais
pas dans un sens forcément religieux
type jeu j'ai peur de la religion
puisqu'elle est écrit par les hommes
donc elle est forcément écrites pour
mener
une masse et pas très intelligente mais
je crois qu'on a besoin de croire en
quelque chose de plus grand que l'homme
puisque l'homme est très prétentieux je
crois que ça peut s'appeler dieu et que
je crois que c'est bien rendu donc tu
crois en bio ça ça peut s'arrêter comme
ça
est ce que tu as déjà essayé d'embrasser
quelqu'un à travers une grille le
confessionnal non même toi mon petit
chat ta femme noble 1